Lindsey Graham is running for president
and the guy is fascinating and it's not
just cuz his name makes him sound like
the popular cheerleader in high school
Lindsey Graham got great skin he wants
to be President even though 58% of
people in his home state of South
Carolina
say that he shouldn't try fun fact South
Carolina is also a state where schools
are required to teach an NRA approved
unit on the second amendment that lasts
three weeks that's one week longer than
they learn about slavery and two weeks
longer than their sex ed unit which
hasn't been updated in 27 years it's
still just a run down of you show me
yours if I show you mine maybe that's
how Lindsey Graham has managed to remain
single for 60 years which admittedly is
awesome and if led some to call him
ambiguously gay to which I say aren't we
all a little he also doesn't use email
you can have every email I've ever sent
I've never sent one you're kidding me
right
you mean to say that the president could
also be the same jerk who doesn't know
the difference between reply and reply
all but not everything about Senator
Graham is from the Stone Age he agrees
climate change is man-made and on
immigration understands that the idea of
asking 11 million people to self-deport
isn't like screaming last call at a bar
and hoping for the best
yet that's about where Graham's foothold
in reality ends on the economy Graham
says he wants to cut entitlement
spending even though South Carolina
relies on seven times the amount of
federal money as it pays in federal
taxes no matter what's his plan to help
the 18 percent of South Carolinians who
live in poverty go visit them you're all
invited to come spend money when you do
but either way spend money we need to
help comeback spend money in fact why
don't I just pass a collection plate
right now listen I don't care how many
Myrtle Beach keychains you sell you can
fix unemployment that way they're not
even made anywhere near Myrtle Beach but
in grams book there is an endless amount
of money for one thing military spending
fund DHS reached
defense spending yes there's nothing
ambiguous about lindsey graham's foreign
policy on iran they lied they cheat
they're not trustworthy
they killed Americans on Isis in Iraq
but going into a rock if I know now what
then what I know now would I have
launched a ground invasion probably not
but that's yesterday's thinking what do
we do today and tomorrow and the day
after so what do we do today according
to Lindsey Graham American Graham
Component American boots on the ground
somewhere around 10,000 troops so what
we did yesterday maybe if the senator
had email he'd have gotten the Iraq memo
and his solution to the radicalization
of Muslims put radical Islam in a box
and shut it tightened what this isn't a
middle school science project
we just seal it up real good and poke
some holes in it and never ever open it
I think I'll call it Pandora